pas de bray ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
premier ministre
dans quel pays vivons nous dans quel
pays des centaines de chauffeurs de
taxis peuvent entraver la circulation de
la capitale des grandes villes et des
aéroports dans quel pays ce même groupe
peu sous le nez des passants des caméras
des forces de l'ordre envahir le pays
périphériques
ils brûlaient des pneus jeté des
projectiles sur les crs
ce matin les habitants de la porte
maillot et et tous les français ont
assisté médusés à des scènes d'émeutes
urbaines en plein coeur de paris
et ceci en plein état d'urgence
les crs et les pompiers au péril de leur
sécurité sont intervenues au milieu de
la circulation et je tiens à saluer leur
courage et leur professionnalisme
mais ce n'est pas la première fois sous
votre responsabilité que les forces de
l'ordre sont dépassés malmené depuis
les scènes de guérilla urbaine se sont
multipliées trocadéro siemens avec un
mort nantes la porte maillot
déjà le 25 juin l'autoroute un mois rend
et encore ce samedi à calais pourquoi
n'avez-vous pas anticiper ces déborde de
débordements qui était annoncé quel
maillon affaibli dans la chaîne de
commandement
quelles réelles responsabilités du
préfet de police
et quelle est la responsabilité du
ministre de l'intérieur dans six mois
la france va accueillir l'euro 2016
vous rendez vous compte de l'image
délétère que provoque sur notre pays ces
débordements non maîtrisée monsieur le
premier ministre des sanctions sévères
doivent être prises contre les auteurs
de ces actes par irad doit retrouver sa
sérénité
nous sommes en état d'urgence vous
souhaitez même
avez-vous dit le prolonger mais la
parole et à monsieur bernard cazenave
minutes à l'intérieur
sur le député bernard debré je voudrais
vous poser une question en moto qui sera
une manière de répondre à votre propre
interrogations en 2005 lorsqu'il y a eu
trois semaines d'émeutes urbaines en
france et trois semaines d'état
d'urgence qui n'était pas dictée par le
terrorisme mais par la capacité dans
laquelle vous aviez été après un mot
malheureux du ministre de l'intérieur de
l'époque de maintenir l'ordre
est-ce que nous étions dans un pays qui
était capable de faire régner l'état de
droit je vous pose la question je vous
pose la question vous êtes
singulièrement oublieux de ces moments
vous qui donnez des leçons en même temps
que pendant cinq ans vous avez mis à mal
les forces de l'ordre en supprimant
treize mille emplois au sein des forces
de l'ordre en diminuant leurs crédits de
10 7% et en faisant en sorte que dans la
magistrature
le même sort soit réservé à ceux qui
sont là pour faire passer le droit alors
quand on a de tels diplômes on se
dispense de donner des leçons d'état de
droit et de sécurité maintenant laissez
moi vous répondre sur le fond
monsieur le député debré rené coach
alain pons avait pas l'interdiction de
manifester en tout point du territoire
national parce que si c'était cela ce
sera un état arbitraire qui remettrait
en cause les libertés publiques
et si nous avions pris la décision
d'interdire cette manifestation nous
aurions été cassé par le juge
administratif
ce qui aurait affaibli l'état de droit
et c'est parce que nous n'avons pas
voulu l'affaiblir que nous n'avons pas
pris les décisions hasardeuses que vous
avez prises ou même et qu'il s'agisse de
moirans qu'il s'agisse de roi qu'il
s'agisse d'ajaccio partout les
interpellations ont eu lieu partout le
droit passera par ce que le tas de droit
ce n'est pas l'état d'agitation
merci monsieur le ministre d'intérieur
la parole est à monsieur razzy hammadi